[Music]
Springtime in Paris after a season of
pension protests now it's crunch time
for the 12th week There's Been organized
action across France driven by unions
and ordinary workers underpinned by
crippling strikes supported by the young
and old so you're 68 now what difference
did it make to you retiring at 62.
oh okay well it's uh it was a relieving
because I I can enjoy the life
this demonstration is particularly
significant people really want to get
their voices heard because it comes on
the eve of a critical ruling which will
decide whether or not the French
government under President Emmanuel
macron acted within the French
constitution in trying to raise the
pension age from 62 to 64.
[Applause]
in Paris and in other cities things
inevitably turned violent the
demonstrations have gone on for so long
it's almost like choreographed theater
with a rump of Hardcore protesters the
so-called Black Block Adept at playing
cat and mouse with the riot police
but there's more to the anger on this
pension issue the demonstrators say
France is no Beacon of democracy
president macron has tried to bypass
Parliament where he doesn't hold a
majority to push the measures through
and it's not just about raising the
pension age no no no I guess we we are
here for all the problems we have in
France not all about
because it's more than that way Mom
attendance president McCall says the
pension changes are a necessity in the
face of spiraling inflation and the cost
of living
the decision of France's constitutional
Council will likely embolden one side or
the other though it's hard to see how
the protests even in the face of tear
gas and determined police tactics will
easily subside Lisa Holland Sky News
Paris